JK Rowling hates my video and I could
really use your help
so our Winston got a tweet from JK
Rowling who's mentioned she hates the
top ten rules video that I made on her
and I don't know that she actually
watched the video or not but she tweeted
out and she said god I hate this stuff
I've wind it my whole life I messed up
regularly there are no rules do your
thing and then later on she goes on the
right Thank You xx very happy to be an
inspiring screw-up just don't want to be
repackaged as a smug Roebuck so I need
to be honest this hurt a little bit I've
never had anybody call my videos and
used the words hate or smug relate to
them a lot of people have seen the top
ten rules video that I made on them
fifty Cent watched it and shared it
Floyd Mayweather watched and shared it
people been involved in their own
version of the top ten like Ryan holiday
and Chris Guillebeau and so far all the
feedback has been insanely positive and
again I don't know if JK Rowling
actually watched the video or just feels
like I pack you did together and and
she's upset about that it also doesn't
help that the way she found the video
was through some guy who was trying to
promote credit card processing so I
don't know if she actually even saw the
video or not or just saw that was
related to some credit card processing
website and got upset I wanted to make
sure that my intention behind the videos
is always to honor the person that I'm
showcasing right it's always a positive
it's never the top ten worst moments of
JK Rowling or the top ten biggest
screw-ups on camera of JK Rowling I
think there's enough of that online
there's enough of that putting people
down and hating on people and that's
that was never the intention I never
want to create content that is that is
making people hate on each other right I
think we have too much of that and so
the intention is always positive
intention is always to show off their
best work the intention is always to be
an inspiration to people who are trying
to do more and are trying to
get better a lot of you probably know JK
Rowling from her books but you may not
have never have been inspired by here
you may not have seen this feature she's
done an interview she's given and the
message that she has as an entrepreneur
and my intention isn't to say that these
are the only 10 things you can learn
from JK Rowling and follow this and
you'll be successful like her hopefully
that doesn't come across from you guys
watching videos it's more I'm just
trying to I'm just trying to expose you
guys to people who've done a lot more
than us expose myself to it to to be
surrounded by these people who've done
great things and try to absorb some
wisdom from them and try to learn from
them to be the best version of ourselves
maybe you see something in JK Rowling
story that you can relate to that you
can say man I'm just like her and you
know if she can overcome those obstacles
then I can too and gives you a little
bit of hope and inspiration to want to
keep going so I made this video one just
to kind of clarify my position but to I
like to ask for your help what I'd like
to do is make a video to send the JK
Rowling and I'd love to include ten
videos from you guys believe nation
talking about how the video that we made
moved you talking about what you've
learned from that video how you become a
better person or an entrepreneur what
you've learned from it and and I want to
include those 10 videos together along
with a message from me and we're going
to put it up and send it to her if
you're gonna do it though please I don't
want any negativity okay I don't
appreciate that a lot you guys may want
to defend me but in doing so don't put
anybody else down don't don't tell her
that her tweet was you know off-base or
whatever language you want to use just I
just really want to focus on the
positive I just really want to show that
the video that we made about her and her
rules moved you helped you changed you
motivated you so that she can realize
that it's having an impact and that it's
not just trying to promote something
it's not just some kind of smug thing to
get some
tension and awareness but that it's
having a real meaningful impact on
people's lives and if at the end of the
day she hasn't asked me to but if at the
end of day she wants me to remove the
video I'll do it because again it's
supposed to be a tribute to her and I
don't like the idea that it's out there
making her feel bad
that she hates it but before doing that
I'd love for her to see the impact that
it's having on people's lives so I'd
encourage you to watch the video if you
haven't I'll link it up in the
description and maybe we will put an
annotation for the annotation right
there if you guys to watch it watch the
video if you want to participate make a
I'd say up to thirty second video reply
up to what it meant to you and address
it right to JK Rowling and we're going
to pick the top ten of those and mix
them together send a video message to JK
Rowling I really appreciate your help I
really appreciate your support looking
forward to what comes back you can link
up your video by leaving a comment down
below on this video thank you guys again
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you soon